good morning everybody it is a seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
the PM's in Bali there's the G20 meeting
of world leaders gets underway with a
warning for Vladimir Putin that Russia
will hear a chorus of global opposition
to the war in Ukraine we'll bring you
all the latest live from Bali this
morning and we'll hear from the chair of
the defense select committee that's
Tobias Elwood from Ukraine and the
former head of the British army Lord
Janet back home ahead of the Autumn
statement this week we'll be joined by
Labor's Lisa nandi lots to come in a
very busy program it's Tuesday the 15th
of November
get out of Ukraine the prime minister's
message to Moscow as the G20 gets
underway in Indonesia
I'm live in Bali as world leaders gather
the global impact of Russia's war in
Ukraine top of the agenda
a warning from NHS bosses who say
they're more worried about this winter
than any before it
a lack of Staff gaps in rotors means
that trusts can't provide the high
quality of care that they would like to
provide
and today the health secretary will meet
union bosses to try and avert the
growing threat of coordinated strikes
that could [ __ ] the NHS
the head of the Civil Service Union
calls for changes to how ministerial
complaints are handled after allegations
of bullying made against the Deputy
Prime Minister
I'm live from Lagos which is expected to
become the world's largest city by the
end of the century
also had the impact of the cost of
living crisis on pets we'll speak to a
national charity calling for more
support
and joined by the man who built himself
an arm out of Lego after years of hiding
is Miss England
morning everybody the Prime Minister has
told Russia to get out of Ukraine as the
leaders of the world's biggest economies
Gather in Bali this morning for the G20
meeting of the world's largest economies
according to Downing Street Richard
sunat criticized Vladimir Putin for not
joining the meeting and said Russia will
never have a legitimate seat at the
table faced with a growing cost of
living crisis and ahead of the Autumn
statement on Thursday the PM is expected
to use the summit to call for countries
to end their dependents on Russian
exports let's get more should we from
our Asia correspondent Cordelia Lynch
joining us live from the summit gets
underway today although there have
already been some bilateral meetings
haven't they Cordelia good morning
thank you
good morning to you yes we saw President
Biden of America and president Xi
Jinping of China yesterday Meeting those
two have been going through a very tense
period uh in relations between them but
we saw both men trying to Signal a
conciliatory tone they talked about both
wanting to ensure that they weren't
sliding towards another cold war period
they talked about their red lines about
the desire not to go towards conflict in
the Taiwan Straits something that has
been a cause of international
concern recently so that was certainly a
sign of progress it was the first
face-to-face meeting since uh Joe Biden
became president aside from that though
what is looming large Central to this
Summit is the war in Ukraine now
Vladimir Putin is not present but he has
sent his foreign minister Sergey lavrov
a man who's often accompanied with a bit
of drama now there was news yesterday
that he had been rushed to hospital with
a heart condition a claim that he
dismissed arishi sunak the British prime
minister really wanted to take this
moment his first real test on the global
stage to make clear his position on the
war in Ukraine as something he referred
to this morning in the opening session
with world leaders where Sergey lavrov
was present as a barbaric War he called
on Russia to end it he talked about a
global chorus of opposition and he
connected it too with the economic
challenges that the world is facing I
mean this of course being a gathering of
industrialized nations that are all
staring down the barrel of an imminent
recession the key question though is
what material progress are they going to
make as a result of this is Sergey
lavrov there's always been a concern
that no community will be published I
think that is the expectation and that's
in part because Russia will not agree of
course to condemn itself and the world
leaders have not been able to agree so
far on wording when it comes to Russia's
war in Ukraine so it may be viewed by
many people as a diplomatic failure
ultimately of a kind of Toothless Summit
if you like but everyone present Keen to
show some kind of material achievements
we will have to wait and see but Rishi
sunak I think very deliberately trying
to stake his claim to a global politics
his positioning when it comes to Russia
as well and he'll have more of that as
we go on throughout the day interesting
isn't it cloudy Claudia forgive me that
um there's a lot of criticism for Putin
for not coming but even if he had come
most of the leaders would not sat down
with him
yeah look this is fundamentally very
awkward dynamic because I think if he
forced that position there was talk of a
possible walkout there's been talk as
well of a walk out on Sergey lavrov so
far we have not seen that take place but
what we're seeing at the moment is a lot
of kind of strident language but not
much Beyond so I think they have their
back somewhat against the wall they need
to see how hard they can press on Russia
and Sergey lavrov is known for some
unpredictable theatrics but look if they
come out of this G20 Summit in Bali all
the costs and efforts associated with no
real kind of commitments on Ukraine and
no real material changes when it comes
to staving off the threat of a recession
globally I think many people will be
asking well what's the point
okay
um for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
um Cordelia obviously we're going to get
more information
um from the G20 throughout the course of
the day including an interview that we
are presently carrying out with um Rishi
sunax so do stay tuned for more uh on
that meantime I want to talk to you
about what's happening with the health
service and Steve Barclay we'll meet
union bosses later on today to try to
avert the looming threat of strikes in
the NHS nurses have already voted in
favor of walkouts over pay as you know
with other NHS workers including
ambulance Crews midwives Hospital
Porters and cleaners currently being
balloted meanwhile bosses from a number
of NHS trusts say they're more worried
about this coming winter than any other
check this out report by NHS providers
found that 87 say this winter will be
worse than any before it uh 86 also say
they're worried about meeting demand for
services over the next 12 months and 93
say they're concerned about staff
burnout 94 are worried that not enough
investment is being made in Social care
the interim Chief exec of the NHS
providers told Sky News this will have
an impact on the quality of care
we know that a a lack of Staff gaps in
rotors means that
trusts can't provide the high quality of
care that they would like to provide so
it means that people may need to wait
longer for appointments it may mean that
on Wards they need to wait longer to be
attended to and that isn't ideal and in
some scenarios it may mean that
appointments or procedures are canceled
and nobody wants to see that because we
know how long people have been waiting
and this isn't just for hospital care
and routine procedures we are talking
about Mental Health Services and
Community Services as well
let's get more on this should we with
either hi Ivo we do know that the health
secretary is engaging with unions what
hope is that
yeah it's pretty bleak stuff this isn't
it and the most pressing consent really
for the government is this threat of
strike action that's why the health
secretary Steve Barclay will be meeting
union bosses here later this morning to
try another a mass walkout at the moment
only nurses have voted to strike but
according to the telegraph the sixth
largest Health unions have already
balloted members and discussed a
coordinated Mass walkout to try and
maximize disruption and if that went
ahead it wouldn't just be nurses who'd
be striking it'd be midwives paramedics
ambulance technicians Hospital cleaners
Hospital Porters also 999 corn handlers
and if that went ahead I think it'd be
the NHS itself on life support strikes
however as we've heard there and from
that survey are only one aspect of of
the problems the NHS faces which has
prompted this dire warning from
Healthcare bosses on top of that this
winter there's also all the usual winter
pressures but also the potential covid
resurfacing we've got the record long
waiting list more than seven million
people waiting for treatment there's
severe staff shortages the cost of
living crisis the problems are
everywhere Healthcare bosses look
the Department of Health have come back
to us with a statement in reply to this
this survey saying that they are working
to boost capacity they're working to
develop a long-term plan to recruit and
retain staff long-term plans are one
thing clearly the concern here though is
the immediate term the short term okay
everyone I thank you thanks a lot let's
return now to what's happening in Bali
and of course in Ukraine as well joined
by the chair of the defense select
committee Tobias Elwood who's in Odessa
in Ukraine this morning hello to you Mr
Elwood it's good to see you thanks for
joining us um first of all why are you
there
well firstly to better understand what
is actually happening here where the
critical uh juncture in this War uh with
Russia and there's huge appreciation I
should say for the British commitment to
what we've done to help ukrainians push
back the the third largest army in the
world and but Putin is now humiliated
and there's huge concerns that he's
going to go more extreme he's going to
find uh more imaginative way ways to
raise the stakes and uh he's starting to
regroup the other side of the danipa
river and it's so important that that
message is said at the G20 as the Prime
Minister has been underlying that we
don't give up now that we don't sign a
deal that we don't step back but we're
able to flush Russia completely out of
Ukraine and that's certainly the strong
message that we're getting here myself
and the defense Select Committee do you
think that President Putin should have
attended the G20 Summit in Bali
yes understandably why he didn't the
last time he turned up uh at a an
International Conference uh he was
humiliated I think by the Indian Prime
Minister and others who said what are
you doing in Ukraine so he sent lavrov
uh instead but ultimately uh lavrov is
just going to give us the lines that uh
Putin is spouting to say that this is
nobody else's business it is our
business because you know the Green
Ships behind me are not moving as as
they should do and uh Security in
Eastern Europe is everybody's security
if we don't flash Russia out of Ukraine
now how can Ukrainian economy move
forward how can the Sovereign identity
of Ukraine exist this is the time to do
it if we sign any deal now all Russia
will do is regroup to attack again in a
year or two's time it has to happen now
I thought a deal had been done as far as
the grain was concerned bread basket of
Europe of course to get it out of uh
Odessa and to parts of the world that
need it most what happened
yeah I mean but this shows that Russia
has continued to be setting the agenda
we've been following it this was
Russia's deal and they controlled the
movement of ships but actually this as I
suggested before should be an
international humanitarian Safe Haven
with the UN stamp of approval that
removes Russia from it you have you know
Ukrainian territorial Waters here
linking up to international waters in
the Black Sea that should have nothing
to do with Russia yet Russia is the one
that set this deal and only one-fifth of
those chips are actually leaving this
port meaning that the world Africa and
indeed Europe has not been fed on the
scale and of course that causes rises in
food prices knock-on inflation problems
elsewhere so we need to lean further
into this this is the moment now to take
the responsibility of this um a port
away from from Russia back to Ukraine
and the International Community
there have been some successes we've
seen what's happened in Curson and we've
seen that president zielinski has gone
along to um congratulate his troops and
also to offer uh Solace and support to
those that live then have lived under
Russian uh control for the last eight
months but Jen stoltenberg NATO
Secretary General has urged the West not
to make the mistake of underestimating
Russia you would agree with that
a hundred percent I mean firstly occurs
on is massively humiliating for uh Putin
they've had to withdraw across the
danipu river but they Russia still has
control of you know the size of Portugal
in Ukraine so this is far from over so
again stolenberg is absolutely right uh
to encourage NATO members to continue
providing that individual bilateral
support as Britain is doing because
Munitions and so forth weapon systems
they need to keep going the back the
battle is actually moving away from the
battlefield as I said with Putin
attacking electricity electric
electricity and infrastructure and so
forth trying to uh break the morale of
the of the Ukrainian people by you know
freezing them out this winter but at the
moment the actual uh there is a lull in
war fighting because there will be a
spring offensive and that's what we need
to build up and prepare for
although anzalenski looking at these
pictures has said that this illustrates
the beginning of the end of the war do
you not agree with him
no no absolutely I do because it's
showing that Russia can't uh hold the
line that uh the Ukrainian defensive the
incredible fighting will of the
Ukrainian forces
um are able to then push back but this
isn't the moment as I say uh to sign
that deal to leave Russia in control of
part of Ukraine it requires additional
effort it means another six months or a
year if you like
um of what we're doing now and the worry
is is that the West's interest
commitment that so far will start to
drain away we we don't have good form on
this if you look at all the places that
we've been to to try and provide you
know a Force for good from Libya Somalia
um Afghanistan Iraq Syria and so forth
we've actually given up and gone home
leaving problems there we mustn't do the
same here this is in everybody's
interest but particularly of course
Ukraine's that we stay here uh and see
this through
where does this leave us when it comes
to how much of our GDP we will be
spending on defense going forward we
know that Liz trust said that that was
going to be three and a half percent uh
when pushed Rishi sunak said to me
during the summer about
um two and a half percent although Ben
Wallace said that when he was at the
treasury he was forced to say that he
was overruled by the Prime Minister and
the ladies were Hearing in the papers
this morning as it could be less than
two and a half percent our defense
budget what would you say in response
yeah well we're slowly understanding and
appreciating why hard power matters why
a strong defense is absolutely critical
to defend our interests whether they're
around the UK or actually here in uh
Ukraine there is a symbiotic
relationship between our economy between
our prosperity and our ability to trade
around the world and the world is
getting more dangerous not less so we
drop our guard at our Peril that will
affect our economy and I hope that's the
message that we'll hear on Thursday from
the chancellor who he himself as former
foreign secretary recognizes the
importance there's also an absence of
International Leadership dare I say we
are doing much better at stepping
forward encouraging others to follow
it's tougher to do that if you don't
have the hard power yourselves to
provide that example
um we're hearing that the traditional
G20 Family Photos actually been called
off one wonders how much this Summit
might actually achieve but then you look
at the fact that the Chinese leader and
the U.S president have got together face
to face for the very first time does
that give you
um some sucker
I think we should always uh welcome uh
conversations between the two world's
largest Powers China and the United
States absolutely but I for one will not
you know drop my guard in in being
concerned about where China is going in
the long term and its symbiotic
relationship with Russia despite what
they say publicly in our lifetimes China
will become uh Stronger larger than the
United States militarily economically
technology technology and that's
important to understand as to how we
manage that how we actually defend our
International values and standards which
China is Keen to exploit so of course we
welcome these talks but don't you know
kill ourselves that China still wants to
uh is watching carefully what's going on
here because it still wants to lay claim
to Taiwan
um final thought before I let you go in
on domestic politics
um Liz truss and her then
um Chancellor uh not Rishi sunak of
course quasi kwashing apparently uh
their mini budget cost the UK economy
something like 34 billion pounds in just
six weeks they've both gone now they're
entitled to 18
000 and 16
000 pounds severance pay if you will
each
um should they take it
well there's other examples of ministers
who have been in office for a very short
time uh offering to give that money back
to the taxpayer or indeed to charity and
so forth I think it's for those two
individuals to work out what they should
do I would say though that it has been a
very difficult uh summer there's no
doubt about it but I've had faith in the
the British democracy the parliamentary
system we are able to flush out you know
a leader uh a government if we're going
in the wrong direction uh and we can do
that quite ruthlessly in a short period
of time unlike other countries United
States for example where if you do get a
leader that's going to take you in the
wrong direction you have to wait four
years so there is a positive there but
ultimately the details you're talking
about it's for the individuals I think
to recognize and do the right thing
what would you do would you give the
money back
yes I think I I I I think there is no
justification for that short short
period of time I'd have become necessary
conversations
um and uh and make sure that you do do
the right thing you've got to be able to
in politics be able to look in the
mirror and say yes I made the right
decision
good to talk to you as always safe
journey back look forward to seeing you
in the studio soon thank you thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning speaking to the head of the
FDA Union which represents civil
servants about his lesser to Rishi sunak
he's asking for a better complaints
process amid the latest bullying
allegations
major supermarkets are asking the
government to expand eligibility for
free School meals we'll hear from
restaurant owner and cookery writer
Henry dimbleby
and former U.S president
Trump of course expected to launch his
Third campaign for the White House today
we'll be speaking to one of his former
campaign advisors later in the program
I should just say thanks for all your
emails and notes yesterday about my cold
it is a lot better it's that one of
those irritating costs right at the end
you know when you can't get rid of it
but thank you for all your notes I
really appreciate it in the last few
minutes the ons has released their
latest monthly unemployment figures what
are they looking like let's find out uh
Godfrey is standing by for us hi good
morning tell us more
good morning yeah there's a lot to look
at in this report but I think the key
takeaway is that the economic downturn
is starting to have a real impact on the
jobs Market the headline rate of
inflation stayed close for a record low
ticked up slightly to 3.6 but what's
really interesting is that the level of
vacancies in the economy which is a
pretty good indicator of the demand for
workers in the economy
fell by 46
000. now it wasn't very long ago that we
were talking about a red hot jobs Market
as we emerged from Lockdown businesses
were really struggling to recruit asking
where have all the work has gone things
are changing now businesses possibly
taking a look at their costs making a
judgment on the economic outlet and
deciding that now is not the time to be
putting out job adverts and that
scarcity for workers that businesses
once experienced isn't going to be a
problem anymore because the bank of
England last week warned that we're
heading for a very prolonged two-year
recession and as part of that the
unemployment rate will close to double
by 2025. so a pretty bleak Outlook but
there is a Slither of good news in there
depending on what perspective you take
of course because one thing that the
bank has been worried about with the
tight labor market is that it could put
pressure on wages fueling inflation
further in the economy at the moment
there are no signs of that although
wages did tick up more than expected
real wages that's when you take
inflation into account fell by 2.6 over
the period so good news for the bank
possibly but not so for workers who are
already seeing the pound in their pocket
being eroded by inflation something
Jeremy Hunt referenced just now in a
statement uh in reference to the labor
market figures
okay but no thank you
looking at some of today's other stories
for you making the news this morning uh
the price of some popular branded foods
have as much as doubled over the last
two years according to research from
which magazine the war in Ukraine and
the rebound from covid Lockdown is said
to be the main reasons
Heinz tomato ketchup can you believe it
saw the biggest average percentage
increase up
by more than 50 percent the average cost
of twinings everyday tea bags has
increased by 17 compared to 2020 and
even basic items like Hovis wholemeal
bread is up 43 now costing nearly two
pounds of loaf
uh head to Sky news.com to see the full
list of 79 items across six major
supermarkets
China signaled that its zero covered
policy could be relaxed with reports
Mass testing could be scrapped instead
the country is looking to implement a
new system where only the vulnerable are
tested
George Eustis who was sacked by Liz
truss as she rushed the trade deal with
Australia in New Zealand Mr Eustace said
the deal was not good for the UK and
blamed her for the negotiations
hundreds of factory workers that a plant
that makes twiglets Jaffa Cakes and
Jacob's cream crackers are striking in a
row over pay the GMB union says that
employees won't return to the entry site
until the company comes back to the
negotiating table
global population has reached a
significant Milestone the United Nations
says more than 8 billion people now live
on the planet projections indicate that
India will surpass China as the most
populous country in 2023. let's get more
should we uh yusra is standing by for us
in Lagos good morning to you what's the
situation there
good morning Kay I mean we're in the
most populated city in Africa and Lagos
is one of the most heaving busy cities
I've ever been to here you can really
feel that the world's population has hit
a billion and that's just over a billion
people in just over 11 years now on
planet Earth Lagos itself has grown
exponentially over the last few decades
it was once a small coastal town and now
it's this heaving City that attracts
people from all over West Africa but the
infrastructure is really suffering and
people have moved to the city for basic
Urban amenities that are now becoming
more difficult you've got power cuts at
least once a day you've got issues with
waste disposal and sanitations and some
poor neighborhoods in the city and
people are really struggling all right
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
well the Prime Minister facing calls to
reform the complaints process of uh
civil or four civil sermons I should say
amid bullying allegations leveled at his
Deputy Dominic Robb let's talk about it
in more detail um I guess with me here
in the studio is the General Secretary
of the FDA Union and that's Dave Penman
hi Davis good morning thanks for joining
us what have you heard
um well what's quite clear is the
credible complaints from a number of
government departments about Dominic
Rabb just like the regrettable
complaints about Gavin Williamson before
it and what's quite clear is that civil
servants do not have confidence in the
current process for raising complaints
against ministers the only way they can
raise a complaint is through the
ministerial code which requires not only
the prime minister to consent in
investigation taking place but the Prime
Minister was the ultimate Arbiter on
that complaint as well and as we saw
with the pretty Patel complaint despite
evidence of booing he refused to
acknowledge that she'd breached the
ministerial code so there's no no real
way that civil servants feel they can
raise complaints which is why this as a
sort of situation we're facing with
speculations coming out into the public
rather than being dealt with through an
effective complaints process let's let's
go back to that but let me just ask you
in a bit more detail what sort of
complaints have you heard about because
the letter that you wrote to the Prime
Minister you didn't even name Dominic
Raab did you no because it's not just
about Dominic lab
um we've had complaints raised with us
about a number of ministers over many
years this is about a system that's not
effective in dealing with uh bullying by
ministers as we saw in Parliament uh
where you have a system that people
don't have confidence in they simply
will not raise formal complaints so when
number 10 say there are no formal
complaints being raised the right but
that doesn't mean that concerns aren't
being raised by civil servants and even
the permanent secretary in the
government Department
um has admitted that his behavior was
tantamount to bullying so we've got a
broken system just now so rather than
concentrating on Dominic Ram Gavin
Williamson we want the prime minister to
reform the entire system for dealing
with complaints against ministers as I
said I do want to come on to that but
um tell me about specific Place
complaints that you've heard about about
Dominic Ralph I don't want to get into
that because it's not because it's not
the forum for it our whole point is what
we shouldn't be doing it's not fair to
Dominic Robin it's not 30 Civil Service
refer to the public if they if you know
if we've got people who are allegedly
bullying in in positions of high offers
the Civil so they're public servants we
should know about it but we should know
and ministers should have an effective
way to either have their name cleared or
for those investigations to be concluded
and to face the consequences if they've
been bullied what we don't think is
appropriate is that accusations are
bandied about in the media that that's
the only way that essentially civil
servants can raise these now because the
internal process isn't working no I
understand that and that's why I'm
pushing you on it if I may please Mr
Penman because the Prime Minister
disagrees with you he says that there is
no evidence that the has been bullying
no he doesn't he says there's no formal
complaints and that's the point people
have no confidence in raising a formal
complaint a formal complaint would
require the prime minister to consent to
investigation and there isn't even
anyone just now who could conduct that
investigation since June we haven't had
an independent advisor on Minister's
interests the cabinet secretaries made
clear civil servants can't investigate
ministers so there isn't even anyone to
investigate a complaint whether that was
a dominant robber whether that was a new
complaint about another Minister this is
not a system that's fit for purpose so
why don't your members make a formal
complaint well we saw what happened when
when they raised a formal complaint you
know when complaints were raised about
pretty Patel the Prime Minister sat on
that report for six months and then
prime minister of course it has a
different prime minister and then um
despite the evidence that she had
bullied civil servants the Prime
Minister refused to accept that refused
to say that she did have done that and
he has acted quickly once was a formal
complaint about Gavin Williams and he
actually quickly and he's not there
that's that's all good and well but he
still hasn't done so so we are in a
situation where the only way that a
complaint can be raised about uh Gavin
Mo sorry governments and or Dominic Rabb
as if the Prime Minister agrees the
prime minister at this point in time
could conduct and initiate an
investigation into Dominic Robb to clear
his name he isn't doing so instead of
that we have this endless speculation
about ministers and civil servants have
no confidence in the current process it
shouldn't be up to the whim of a prime
minister about about whether to support
his political allies on whether an
investigation is conducted into bullying
suggest you know that this Prime
Ministry have you heard a formal
complaint about bullying would say no
he's my mate so I'm not listening I
don't know but that's been the
experience in the past the prime
ministers inevitably and that's not with
this one but what's the test of of
relationship not just now it's uh Easter
well governments in resigned
um is that an investigation into
government so his uh resignation is
essentially means there won't be an
investigation so we actually have an
independent process in Parliament that
even though people resign and leave
Parliament it still concludes it still
brings a conclusion and a potential
punishment and when it comes to
ministers if they design they go off
essentially scot-free and they're free
to come back into a cabinet at later
date the whole system just doesn't work
when it comes to protecting civil
servants from the conduct of ministers
it's only a few ministers it's not it's
not the entire cabinet it's not the
majority but they're all now tainted by
this because no one has confidence in
the system and even if as we saw with
the Patel Affair that there's a
conclusion from it people don't actually
believe it as I said that was a
different prime minister a different era
Richie soon access that he's wiping the
Slate clean are there other
ministers or cabinet ministers that your
members feel have behaved
inappropriately toward them serving
ministers there are yes we've had many I
I don't want to go into speculation of
numbers or complaints it's not
speculation I mean I'm just asking you
how many minutes so you must know people
people reads and concerns with us they
haven't been investigated that's only
one side of a story so I'm not going to
come here and start binding about
numbers or accusations as a result the
whole point about this is we don't have
a process for dealing with this
effectively it's not fair on ministers
and it's not fair on civil servants that
the only way that these sorts of
accusations end up coming out is
speculation in the Press
so
just to be clear your members are
telling you or not potentially you
directly but but your colleagues who are
coming to you to say that there are
several other ministers in Rishi sunax
government who have behaved
inappropriately towards them yes
but you can't tell me how many I'm I'm
not going to go into speculate how many
that's that's pretty can you give me an
idea of what sort of behavior we're
talking about is it bullying yeah most
most of what comes to us as an
appropriate behavior in terms of
ministers whether it's uh was in The
Temper shouting getting frustrated
governments a tough place to work for
both for civil servants and ministers
they know that but at times that
behavior can then Verge into what people
would characterize as bullying and just
like any other workplace that needs an
effective mechanism to address it and
that's not what we have but this is a
conscious this is not your members are
coming to you because they feel they
can't do anything else yeah because they
have no confidence what impact is it
having on them well it blights careers
people end up leaving the job or or
leaving the post that they're in if you
imagine you're a civil servant to work
with ministers who work at the heart of
government it's actually the Pinnacle of
your career that's what you've wanted to
do you want to work in public service
and work close with ministers and help
deliver the government's agenda so for
those who have to leave because that's
the only choice that they've got they
either put up with that behavior or they
leave it's it's hugely damaging to their
careers and of course to their lives
because bullying can have a huge impact
in people's lives and how do you help
them how do you support them through
that well we can support them in terms
of giving them advice about how to deal
with it whether that's a formal
complaint informally broker and getting
another job moving outside of the area
that's sometimes the only option you
know that's the difficulty because it's
more difficult to move a minister than
it is to move in a civil servant
um sometimes that's that's just what
happens and people recognize it but it
can be hugely damaging to individuals of
course I completely get that but just to
clarify it's not just Dominic Robb that
there that there are issues with which
is why you've not named names in the
letter that you've written to the Prime
Minister there are other high-profile
ministers who in your opinion as a union
leader are bullying civil servants and
the prime minister is doing nothing
about it what I'm seeing is that there
are concerns raised about a number of
minutes so that's essentially a constant
in government it's not just about this
government it's every government you
know there that you know there are
dozens of ministers and and stressful
situations and so at any point in time
you're inevitably going to have a
situation where there are concerns
raised about the conduct of ministers
that's why what we're seeing is this
isn't just about Dominic rabbits not
just about Gavin Williams and it's about
the entire system that deals with this
and if you don't have an effective
system for dealing with that sort of
behavior it almost encourages it and and
to what extent do you have some sympathy
for those government ministers who were
in the middle of a war in Europe we've
got a cost of living crisis there's been
turmoil
um over the last six months or so and
they are also up against it absolutely
others are the civil servants that
support them
um loyally and serve government I mean
as I say civil servants who work closely
with ministers are not shrinking
violence they know they've been working
at the heart of government they have to
deal with all of the crises that
ministers have to deal with as well but
they expect to be treated with dignity
and respect and they expect if if
ministers don't do that there would be
an effective effective system for
dealing with it could you talk to you
thank you very much Jenny for joining us
much appreciated thank you
um so other high-profile ministers who
are responsible for allegedly bullying
civil servants we'll talk about that um
two ministers as and when we get the
opportunity before that though let me
tell you
um about this Olympics mascot typically
an animal of some kind rather or mundane
for Paris 2024 is going to be
a red hat apparently two hats one for
the Olympics and one for the Paralympics
was spotted uh posing in sandini outside
Paris the conical Red fridgeon Cat
become uh became rather I should say a
symbol of the pursuit of Liberty during
the French Revolution and is found today
in schools and town halls
there you go will it catch on
still to come after the break speaking
to the co-founder of Leon restaurants
About Preschool meals and how the
country's major supermarkets are calling
our government to roll them out to more
students that come
hello again everybody you're very
welcome to join us here on the breakfast
show Tuesday morning as you can see
tomorrow is here um lots to talk about
today tomorrow good morning to obviously
we've seen that Rishi sunak is um in
Bali for the G20 although there won't be
any photo call apparently at the end he
has been meeting with the Saudi leader
he has he's met with Mohammed bin Salman
just now he interestingly had a fist
bump him he didn't because as he told us
in the uh in the debate he's not fist
bump [ __ ] guy
um he has also been in a closed a
plenary session of the meeting yesterday
in which he criticized
um Russia's barbaric invasion of Ukraine
and in fact Danish put out a picture of
Rishi tunak looking very angry at that
meeting so he has as he promised called
out Russia's Invasion and of course
Russia's Presence at that G20 Summit
makes it awkward for everybody else to
have a photo together so this is what
you see next first moment on the world
stage trying to bond with other
democracies and and as he's put out his
aims for the conference to try and rally
support you know against the Russian
invasion all sorts of problems when he
comes back home of course he's got his
Autumn statement with his new Chancellor
on Thursday but these allegations by
civil servants Union which won't go away
and we know Dominic Raab Deputy Prime
Minister under the spotlight was he the
Justice section now or maybe he's both I
forget but um it seems to change quite
often doesn't it but the uh Dave Penman
telling us just a few moments ago that
several senior
cabinet ministers responsible for
illegible yeah yes I wonder if that
interview that we just heard just now is
going to be the start of something much
bigger Richie sionack promised to lead a
government of Integrity he had to say
goodbye to Gavin Williamson after only a
couple of weeks as Minister without
portfolio because of allegations about
his behavior which Gavin Williamson says
he's going to fight to clear his his
name over we've now heard a drip drip of
allegations against Dominic Robb who's
currently the Justice secretary and also
back as Deputy Prime Minister and
alleged bullying of civil servants it
has been reported last night that the
cabinet secretary Simon case most senior
civil servant was aware of these
allegations although it's it's claimed
by um Dominic Robb's side that there
were no specific complaints ever ever
put forward but if Dominic Robb is now
embroiled in claims about bullying which
he denies so far and plenty of MPS have
rallied his defense is Rishi sooner
going to be under Fire again if any of
these burst out into the open because as
Dave Penman of the Civil Service Union
was saying because civil servants lack
faith in the process for raising
complaints internally within their
departments often they come out later in
the media so it could be that once you
get one claim out in the open several
more people come forward this is
definitely a headache for Richie sunac
and who is taking prime minister's
questions tomorrow in Richie sunx
absence Dominic Robb I wonder if labor
will mention this to him yeah but it's
not just about I think one of the points
from um Dave as you were making there is
that it's not just about Dominic
Robinson he's suggesting that there are
other senior ministers that should also
be onto the spotlight yes we don't know
who they are yet but um he's suggesting
that this does go far wider and the
difficulty the conservatives will have
is that you know when you're putting
people in departments after a very long
time in government you have to look very
carefully at what's you know more
skeletons maybe maybe around there and
certainly British sooner will not want
to after promising to get rid of
um sleaze and bad behavior will not want
to be embroiled in any uh further
problems over this after already having
to lose a member of his cabinet just two
weeks in actually this is what Dave
Penman just told us here on the show
there are concerns raised about a number
of minutes so that's essentially a
constant in government it's not just
about this government it's every
government you know that you know there
are dozens of ministers and and
stressful situations and so at any point
in time you're inevitably going to have
a situation where there are concerns
raised about the conduct of ministers
that's why what we're seeing is this
isn't just about Dominic rabbits not
just about governments and it's about
the entire system that deals with this
and if you don't have an effective
system for dealing with that sort of
behavior it almost encourages it
and that effective system would look
like what
well there's two different things going
on so you've got the system by which
people in Parliament who work in
Parliament raise concerns there's an
independent system for doing that which
has
um been criticized but it's the idea is
to get through the complaints more
quickly and then the difficulty that
he's talking about is in government
departments where um people can raise
concerns under the ministerial code
saying a minister has broken a
ministerial code but they find as Dave
Penman was saying that it's very
difficult to get a hearing for their
concerns and often it's swept under the
carpet and not dealt with and as he says
ministers are in very stressful
situations a lot of the time and it's
difficult to to have a proper process
often to to hear these complaints so um
he's saying that at all levels there are
problems uh with people uh feeling that
they're not going to be listened to and
therefore that's why these things come
out in the media often after the event
okay tomorrow for now thanks very much I
need tomorrow's take at nine o'clock
looking forward to it uh other news
though in major supermarkets are urging
the government to expand eligibility for
free School meals as food insecurity
continues to rise with chefs like Jamie
Oliver and Tom Carriage also supporting
the cause
um in a cosign letter to the education
secretary that's Jillian Keegan they
wrote this as food retailers we
witnessed firsthand the daily struggles
our customers face to feed their
families we are committed to doing all
we can to support them with several
actions set to be implemented in the
coming months but we cannot do this
alone we strongly urge you to consider
the scale of children's food insecurity
across the UK and act without delay to
prevent its devastating consequences
joined Now by cookery writer and
co-founder of Leon restaurants that's
Henry dimbleby hi Henry it's good to see
you this morning
um thanks very much indeed for joining
us on the program uh free School meals
how important are they at the moment
well so this problem has actually been a
long time in the making uh free School
meals represent during term time about
probably about 50 percent of a child's
calories during the day and way back in
2013 when I was asked by government with
my business Father John to do a review
of School meals we already sought down
the cutoff for these free School meals
is very low it's currently at seven
thousand four hundred pounds before
benefit so if you earn more than that
your child doesn't get free School meals
and way back in 2013 we looked at the
people the million children who weren't
eligible that were still living in
poverty and their lunches are they're
eating less they're not getting the
nourishment they need they're not
learning and the problem now in this
cost of living crisis that threshold's
hardly gone up at all over the last 10
years and the problem is uh even greater
than it was then and this is absolutely
essential the government is quite right
the extended for useful meal provision
into the holidays it now needs to ensure
that the eligibility for that is all
children of poverty not just those right
right at the bottom of the uh of the
pile
and what what impact does it have the
lack of access to free School meals uh
for some kids I'm I'm looking at some
facts and figures here the food
Foundation estimating that 800 000
children in England are living in
poverty but they don't qualify for free
School meals
so there is a lot of data on it so that
they they don't learn they're
undernourished I mean it's it's it's
sacking children back uh in life but I
think I was talking to a head teacher uh
in a school just the other day and he
was describing what that looked like
what those numbers looked like in in
practice and he was talking about a
young girl who was quite aggressive she
always used to barge the front of the
dinner queue to get a seat where she
could eat her packed lunch with a seat
next to the wall and he realized that
what she was doing was the fact that
actually there was hardly anything in
her back Blanche box and she was ashamed
so she was pretending to eat a pack
lunch while facing the wall and I'm in
schools all the time I have a charity
that that helps schools improve their
School meals and it is worse than I have
ever seen at those stories you hear all
the time children not able to eat not
able to learn hungry and I know there
are a lot of trade-offs that government
have to make at the moment in terms of
spending but surely supporting the diet
of our most vulnerable children has to
be at the top of the list
okay what do you want to say to Jillian
Keegan the education secretary
well what I'd like to say is first of
all this has always been a problem that
has been dealt with thrown around
government so get together with the
Secretary of State for for potential for
work and pensions get together with the
Prime Minister and work out what your
strategy is for these poorest children
in society and then secondly look at the
data and you will realize that part of
that strategy has to come from your
department uh expanding the eligibility
for free School meals it's 10 years out
of date uh and it is the best thing that
you could do for those children as we go
into this winter that as we all know
it's going to be pretty grim
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed for joining us thank you thank
you
expecting a big announcement huge from
Donald Trump today the former U.S
president expected to say whether or not
he'll Run for the White House again in
2024 but as the results of last week's
midterm elections continue to trickle in
one of the former presidents key backers
Carrie lake has lost her race in the key
swing state of Arizona according to U.S
media projections in the last few hours
our correspondent Martha Kellner has the
latest
this was one of the closest elections of
any across this country it was also one
of the most closely watched and that's
because of who Carrie lake is and what
she stands for she is undeniably a
magnetic performer she was a local news
broadcaster for a fox affiliate station
in Arizona so she knows how to hold an
audience but she used her platform to
become arguably the most prominent
purveyor of Donald Trump's live at the
2020 election was stolen she she called
that on the campaign Trail crooked and
corrupt election that 2020 election she
also attacked on numerous occasions what
she called the fake news media but more
than half of Arizona voters have
rejected Carrie Lake and what she stood
for in favor of Katie Hobbs the
Democratic nominee there who will become
the Democratic governor
a little bit later on
um this evening from Mar-A-Lago whether
or not president Trump plans to run in
2024 meantime care England warns that
the care sector under threat unless
government acts immediately and that a
lack of central government investment in
the workforce means there won't be
enough care workers to look after our
loved ones in the future as you can see
Martin green director uh Chief exec of
care England joining me now hi it's good
to see you thanks for joining us on the
program what challenges is the care
sector facing we have a serious funding
shortage and we also have a serious
Workforce shortage so skills for care
data showed that there were 154
000 vacancies in Social care and that
was up 52 percent on their previous data
so I think you'll see that not only have
we got this funding crisis but we've
also now got a Workforce crisis and
that's going to mean that people are not
going to get services and that's going
to put huge pressure on families and
local call services particularly local
authorities why is that well I think
it's down to money K the bottom line is
that there is not enough money in the
system our colleagues do the most
amazing work and they have a very
skilled job to do but they're not paid
appropriately we don't have a Workforce
strategy in Social care where there is a
Workforce strategy in the NHS and we're
constantly competing with the NHS but
we're not given either the money or
indeed a Workforce strategy so that
people can know they can have careers in
Social care
increasing the basic wage which is what
is one of the ideas that's been floated
as part of the Autumn statement how
would that help because that's
suggesting that um those wages would
increase by 10 yeah I think we should
remember that this is a very complicated
job and I think we need to put the
people who work in Social Care on a
different footing so it's not about just
increasing the wage which is pretty
inadequate at the moment by 10 percent
it's also about saying we need to have a
proper career structure and people need
to know they have careers in Social care
there might be an entry level but they
know that they can quickly rise up the
ladder and get a lot more money and also
a lot more training and development so I
think it has to be part of a long-term
Workforce strategy social care crisis
what impact does that have on the NHS
because we're hearing that a lot of
people who are in hospital a lot of
people are in hospital
don't need to be there
um but there's no there's no support for
them if they come out of Hospital yeah
it's having a huge impact on the NHS and
as you say there are people in hospital
now who don't need to be but the reason
they're there is because they can't get
social care packages but of course
that's the thing that gets the publicity
but they're about 10 times as many
people in local areas waiting for social
care assessments and services so it's
not only a problem for the NHS but it's
also a problem for people who are not
getting the support they need and what
will happen to those people is they'll
go into crisis and probably go into
hospital and then that compounds the
problem in the NHS
and so as a social Care Service always
been a Cinderella service yes it has
unfortunately you know we've never
really had the same status as the NHS
but we are a absolutely integral part of
a Health and Social care sector and what
we need to see is parity of esteem we
need to see pay and conditions aligned
and we need to see social care respected
particularly because it does a very
complex role and the same people are in
the NHS are the same people who are in
Social care
and do you envisage potentially
industrial action as we're seeing um
increasingly in the Health Service in in
Social Care Service I don't think we'll
see industrial action but what we will
see is Care staff walking and getting
other jobs because there's higher pay
and they're less difficult jobs so in
effect what we'll see is a reduction in
the amount of services available so it
won't be quite as Stark as industrial
action but the impact will be enormous
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
in the studio this morning thank you
um coming up in the next hour of the
program we were hearing from the civil
servants Union uh leader in the last
hour and he has basically been telling
us that there is a significant problem
with senior ministers allegedly bullying
their staff he wouldn't go into any
names or pack drill but he did say it
was something that the Prime Minister
when he comes back from the G20 in Bali
really does need to get his head around
a Preston on his specific examples of
what might have happened and he talked
about shouting and bullying by senior
ministers we talk about that with labor
in just a few moments time listen Andy
will be with us here on the program